>> Hello. I'm Danny McClennahan. This is EMAX-2024, and this presentation is ostensibly
about EMAX-REJECS compilation, but it'll lead a lot more in future directions. Thanks
for coming on this journey with me. This presentation is 50 slides, 50 footnotes, and that's intended
for it to be a resource later on figure perusal, where unfortunately not going to be able
to go into all of it, but I will try to be within 20 minutes so we can make it throughout
Q&A. So this is the structure of the talk, but enough about me. Who are you? And why
are you here? So I'm Danny McClennahan. My experience is a lot of build tools, especially
in the package managers, and that started because I realized I was wasting a lot of time,
and then I didn't like that. And so I started wasting a lot of time trying to avoid wasting
time. And then I ended up going so far around that I ended up stopping other people from
wasting their own time, in this case, regarding failing builds, but this is a kind of pattern
that you'll see. I'm talking a lot about patterns in this presentation. So parsing in text
is another one of those tendencies that I have. And why am I here? I've got a lot of
feelings about text, and for the next 20 minutes, I'm making it your problem. So first off,
a huge shout out to EMAX DeVel and the EMAX community in general. I spent a lot of time learning
about what I'm about to kind of talk about. I was definitely super confused at first. And
then when I became less confused and I decided I was going to look at the regular expressions
of the magic engine. I was like, oh, it's old C code, it's normal. You know, we can just
use modern techniques. And it turns out, you know, that's wrong for kind of two reasons. One
because these other using modern techniques or other engines don't necessarily do what EMAX
Reddix engine currently does. And then secondarily, that's not actually as interesting as the other
kind of larger goals that EMAX DeVel discussed. Thank you, Eli Zaretski so, so much, especially
and Pipset and everyone else as well. I leave Pipset. I hope I'm pronouncing that correctly.
Thank you so much. And I'll be shutting you out later as well. And then I, these larger
goals ended up overlapping a lot with my own research interests. And that's very exciting.
So I'm hoping it's exciting for you too. So what is a regular expression? And when
and how does implementation match for all theory? So what does formal theory mean? And you'll
talk about that. So so what is a regular expression? So I might ask you this question and you might
give an answer. None of mine asked someone else and they might have an answer. And then I
might ask myself and I might try to think of an answer. And our answers would, you know, see
the thing is they'd all be correct, but they probably be slightly different and they'd be
different in kind of important ways. And so I'm using formal theory to kind of describe
what unifies these interpretations and what causes this sort of divergence both over time
and then, you know, across to a basis. So I'm kind of, you know, putting a flag in the ground
here and saying formal theory is actually really, really negative influence. I think, but it can
be better and that's what I'm going to talk about in this in this presentation. So we might ask,
how did this happen? And we might, you know, try to find a, you know, a start state. And we
might put that place at the series of formal languages that kind of arose, especially, you know,
post a, a turning and post Chomsky. And especially there is a really, really interesting and powerful
relationship with formal languages between representation and computation. And then on top of that,
we have red X as this really powerful union of theory and practice. And then, like I mentioned,
this is kind of divergence that kind of occurs. And so this divergence, you know, happens for a good
reason. This happens because people were adding implementations and the people, adding people
adding features to implementations. And while the people adding these features were often
academics, they were industries, people there were hobbyists, they were interested in building
practical tools. This is a good thing. And this is still a good thing, even though it moves a little
bit away from formal theory. But we start seeing some cracks to developing. And we'll go into that in
a second. We're just going to kind of electric slide into the 1980s here. And we're going to be
confronted with two occurrences very similarly. We might call it, you know, simultaneous discovery.
In 1993, you have Michael Jackson demonstrating the moonwalk. Three years later, we have backtracking
developed to stimulate e-crap style regular expressions. And these would both be incredibly
influential in their own kind of branching paths. So here's where the gloves come off.
Formal theory, I claim, remains largely concerned with incremental improvements to artificial
benchmarks. And much less with expanding models to cover actual user needs. And this isn't just about,
oh, you know, if you listened to users, you know, that you'd be a nicer person, you know,
be a better engineer. What I'm actually saying is that they're missing out. When you don't listen
to applications, you miss out on a lot of fantastic opportunities for novel theory. And so this is,
again, my complaint with formal theory as it stands, but we're going to do better. So before we get
better, we're going to get a little bit worse for a bit. We're going to actually get a little bit
worse as better. And what I mean by that is, you know, by the 1990s, we start looking into these
non-backtracking engines. And this is a bit of a reaction to backtracking. And the current ones
include RE2, hyperscan, and the rest redics library. And these are all great. I'll talk about them later
as well. And they make use of these, you know, they kind of call back to the earlier formal theory,
they have linear runtime for well-specified search tasks. So what happens if that doesn't fit your needs?
We're going to talk about that. So we're going to table that for a second. And we're going to
focus more on EMX, the subject of this conference. So what are rejects used for? And in this particular
case, they're used for lots of things, with practically, and I think they should be. But more specifically,
how do EMX users use them? And I'm going to focus in on this text as input and output. And I'll be
kind of elaborating on this analogy as we continue. So why is text powerful? Text as I am.
The reason text programming languages, and not just programming languages, but languages themselves,
the reason why they're successful, why they propagate, I claim, is because text is both input,
readable, and output, writeable. And so what this means is that, you know, if you receive, you know,
something in text, you can read it. And then you can also write it. You can modify it, and you could
produce a new version of it. And you're on the same, you're on a kind of level playing field.
But that's not always the case, though. You recall that I worked a lot with the build systems and
package managers. There's a discussion that goes by the name of software supply chain security.
I think it's a massive joke. And the reason why is because people largely raise it to explain why,
you know, their, you know, for-profit company with their, their, you know, for-profit product is
going to solve the problem for you, as opposed to the, you know, the commons of open source.
If you are unable to modify or deploy your code without employing an opaque external system,
I claim, then you have a hidden dependency. And you don't remove a dependency. You just, you know,
by, you know, for example, paying into, you know, a for-profit product or using, you know, I kind of,
you know, closed-off supply chain, you ended up just having a hidden dependency. You ended up just
displacing that. And so this can actually exert arbitrary control over your, your programming output
and potentially even your, your thoughts. This is really important. I'm going to dive in a little
bit deeper and I'm going to overload the term locality here. And I'm going to say if you cannot
reproduce a system locally, it becomes an opaque external system. And I'm going to give examples
here. And these are going to be a bit of a hot take. So first off, gooey IDEs. I think we might,
well, some of us might agree with that here. I say development environments that only allow you to
use a graphical interface. Do not expose interaction with text or explicitly trying to kind of
place you on a separate kind of plain, plain, where you're not an equal contributor to the people who
make the development environment and to make, you know, the development kind of frameworks here,
we'll go one further. Cloud services are precisely, you know, they're useful for things that, you know,
that require large degree of computation, computation. But, you know, Twitter, for example,
you didn't actually ever use any cloud services external ones because it was really important for
them to actually own their own hardware, their own computation, their own, you know, thinking.
And cloud services are a way to ensure that you're unable to reproduce a system without
paying an amount per month, an amount per day, an amount per second, an amount per cycle,
to an external, you know, entity. And I'm just going to kind of conclude this with, I say,
the argument I'm going to add absurdum here, where large language models are all of these at once.
They are a cloud service, specifically, and this is what makes them very evil, to make it so that
similar to GUI IDs, so that text itself loses that ability to be able to readable and writeable.
Instead, text is both unreadable because it's produced by a machine, and then also unreadable
because you're subservient and subjugated to the machine to the large language model,
to produce the code in the first place. So you lose this input, output, readable,
readable behavior that I claim text has specifically. So to underline this, what is text?
Text is local. So finally, we're at the subject of this conference, EMAX, I have double hearts
with text. I start off the slide saying, EMAX is a text editor. I think it's a good start.
And which implements much of its own logic and user interface via text. And so with this means is that,
I say without trying, EMAX tries very hard, but without trying social hard,
EMAX is imbued with all of the capabilities that text has specifically. And when you use text
like EMAX does, and particularly, you then start offering mechanisms to query, to transform,
and to generally metaprogram text itself, you don't just have the ability to edit code in new ways.
And this is something that I think is often lost, maybe not by participants of this conference,
but you particularly start being able to not only just edit code differently,
but to change the way that you think about code, and actually to expand your range of thought,
the range of actions that you can perform, and you can actually start then editing at the speed of thought.
And this is where, especially, rejects kind of comes into play. So finally, we get,
you know, to the subject of the title of this talk, and I'm about to disappoint a lot of people,
and I claim for good reason. Unfortunately, it's a very brief walkthrough,
but I'm going to go over what the current EMAX redx engine is, and this is going to give us
enough context for the next section on future directions. So quickly, it's a backtracking engine
over multi-bite code points. I'll define what that means, and it's in redxemax.c.
It's invoked in two ways, which you'll see is actually the same way over a single contiguous
string input. So this is a, you know, a list string that you passed in, or over the two halves
of the gap buffers. This is when you match against a buffer text, and we'll go into that a little bit
more, but this is one of the really actually interesting and specific things about EMAX redx engine
as it stands. So very, very quickly, this is the data layout. This is just, if you're interested,
this is where the code lies. So redxemax.h has RE pattern buffer, which is a, you know,
a struct, with actually, you know, I love, by the way, I love the EMAX source code. It's so nice
to read. It made all this so, so, so easy. I really appreciate it. So in this particular case,
I'm just going to focus on RE pattern buffer actually has the compiled index. So it's a C struct.
It has every single thing that is needed to execute the regular expression against a string
input or it is the buffer input. And this buffer is not the, you know, an EMAX buffer. It refers to
just the instruction table. And the match loop, and again, this is very, very brief, but I want to
specifically focus on the first part. So this is the, this inner matching loop. And there's a,
you know, a pro, a prologue. And then there's, you know, a loop body. And then there's an epilogue.
And the prologue is the really, really interesting part. I say extract current and next car. So what EMAX
does here, it, it, it doesn't just, you know, reach for the next bite. It actually will perform,
lazily, in some sense, this very, very well integer size variant decoding for multi bite. And it'll
actually then decode the next one to four bites. So up to, you know, 32 bits at once. And then
it'll actually go to the, go into the loop. And so we'll talk about the implications of that later.
We next read the, in the body of the loop, we read the instruction from the instruction pointer,
which is the gain in that buffer field. And then we have this big switch statement, which is
actually, love a big switch statement, super easy to read, super easy to understand kind of what's
occurring. And then that's the loop body. And then at the end of it, we either increment the
instruction pointer. If it was, you know, matching a single character or something along those lines,
or if it was a jump, we don't do that. So I jump, however, though, it's not referring to, you know,
a jump in a sense of a go to, but a jump that's elsewhere within that, you know, a table that
buffer field. And if you've completed a capture, we write that end position there. And of course,
well, as you may recall, the zero capture is of course, any, you know, the entire match string.
And so if the capture is zero, then we know we've actually completed that match. And so that's really
quick. I would love to receive Q&A about this as well. I've spent a lot of time kind of learning
understanding it. But it's really interesting that this can be, you know, described in such a,
you know, in a single slide, because it's really simple. And that simplicity is actually a really
powerful thing. And I'll mention that in the next section. And I say, is that all, and I apologize for
not doing so, but please, please ask questions in Q&A or are messaging about this because I think
it's really, really interesting. And I can find the code relatively easy to read. And so now here's,
I think here, this is actually the point of the talk. The rest of it was, was, was, you know,
I think just me posturing this is the really, really interesting part. And this is the ways that we can
improve, well, not just weak, we improve stuff in Emax. But why those are the right things to improve.
And then also how that can be a model for even things outside of Emax. And so this is going to be
a lot of text. I'm not going to go through all of it. This is the one thing that I tried. This is
the thing that I thought, you know, a slam dunk easy solution. My initial thought process was, well,
we tried very hard to, you know, do an LRU cache here. You know, it works. It's actually very effective.
However, though, we don't actually give the user, you know, the list program or the ability to
then say, I know that this rejects is something that is going to be used again. So I made an artificial
benchmark. I made an artificial benchmark because I wanted to show there is one very specific case
that it does solve. But it's it's the same issue with the artificial benchmarks I mentioned earlier.
It's it's very specifically crafted in order to show that this particular solution would produce
some speedups. So what this means is it has, it just creates more than 20, you know,
rejects in a row. It compiles them. And then of course, because we just don't pay the compile
costs, but because, you know, we don't go through that cache eviction process and it's
being faster. But this doesn't really mean very much. Particularly, the goal here, you know,
the goal would have been to show that the compile cache is actually causing the performance
issue in comparison to pre-compiling it. And that's not something I've been able to show. And so
math overbites not cars. So this is when I said at the beginning, oh, I came in and I think, oh,
we can just use modern revx engine techniques. This is really what I meant. And in particular,
I mentioned in this match loop here that there's this, you know, prologue that does this
varring decoding. And what this means is that every single iteration of that loop is going to be
interspersed with this not being able to read a fixed number of bytes, but a variable number of
bytes, just depending upon, you know, the unit code character or the unit code pointer, the
multivite code point. So this ends up, again, being relatively difficult to optimize because
processors operate over bytes and not over code points. Yeah, we might have a, we could consider
a multivite CPU at some point. But this is a really, really simple thing. It's just generating a
tomata that operate over bytes as opposed to code points. This kind of goes into the much more
abstract one. And there's a lot of text here and we're not going to go into it. But the really,
really important point that I'm specifically mentioning here is this explicit control over
linguistic complexity. And that's like this, that's the abstract kind of point. So I want to
propose or, you know, introduce the inputs and the outputs. And basically when,
perform a search or a match or parse, those are different tasks. And they'll have different
expected inputs and different desired outputs. And so right now, EMAX, the API for the regular
expression engine and for matching, it doesn't allow specialization on this. So rather, if we do
specialize on particular inputs, if we have a heuristic check, if a red X is actually a literal
string, that's not something that the user actually has control over. So for example,
you can make a mistake escaping something and then you don't have a literal and then you accidentally
have behavior that you totally didn't expect. Not just correctness issues, but also performance
issues. So I really like this one. I like this a lot because I didn't think of it at all.
And I think it's better than all of my ideas. So this is, this is proposed, at least to me, to
me by Pipset. And I really hope that I'm pronouncing your name correctly. I'm sorry, I didn't ask you
beforehand. EMAX develop, in particular, this was after a couple of responses where I was trying to
say, oh, I want to give the list programmer way back, you know, in here. I want to give the list
programmer control, you know, the ability to control compilation in some sense. But, you know, he
mentioned, I think he is correct, you know, there's no real introspection. And that happens because
it's written in C. And so I was thinking, oh, if I try this into a list project that gives the
list programmer the power and you know, the ability to do more with that, but it doesn't actually,
because it's still in C. And at first I was thinking, oh, we can make C part more flexible,
but actually, especially if we want to do almost any of the things we previously mentioned,
I think basically this is, this is, I think that, you know, if I'm not going to do it,
somebody else really should do it. And I think we should maybe even do it together, because I think
this is really, I think how we can start experimenting and not just experimenting, but because,
as mentioned here, we have a live DCC jet, we have native compiler, we have the ability to opt,
like specifically to generate specific code for this. So why not implement D or A red X engine
itself in list? And this gives us the ability to introspect it. That's one of the things I mentioned
at the beginning, but it actually gives us the ability to then actually look at all the previous
implementations to explicitly compile a forehand to to to to match against fights, to specialize
in dispatch based upon input and output. And this is something that I, you know, it's super simple.
It's really, it's it's really smart and I'm really, really glad to mention this because it is,
I think the right way to I think to solve the rest of it. So we're at the final section,
and I've talked a lot about, you know, kind of abstract, you know, thoughts and I talked a little
about, you know, specific solutions, but I especially talked about, you know, what is reject
any max? And I don't know if I had a lot of specific examples of it. So I'm going to just describe
kind of my, my, I guess motivation, my impetus. And then I think something that's really something
that you want for the future. So do I have any concrete examples? Yes. Well, you can decide if they're
concrete. Or am I just posturing? Also, yes. Helm, RG, Helmurg. It's literally just mxCrep, but it uses
a rip grip, which is written by the same author of the rest red x3. So it happens to be very, very fast.
In particular, I, you know, use this tool with rip grip on the Twitter Mono repo, and I was able to
search very, very large amounts of code that were that was on my local machine that using regular
expressions. And I think that this is one thing that I think is really, really important because
when you want to, to, to, to scale, you know, there's, there's people say the word scaling and they,
they assume there's a specific kind of answer for that. And I've just found that text is not only
flexible. It's actually something that, you know, that can be more performant than the, than the
alternative, and not only more performant, but more productive. So it's again, it's just mxCrep using
rip grip. There's a tool dead grip by Wilford Hughes. It's also fantastic. I think it's actually better
than this. Um, but, you know, this one's mine. So I can mess around with it. But this tool is kind of
why, especially I started looking into e-max and looking into changing the way that, or at least
diving into how the regular expression matching actually kind of kinds of works, but within e-max
and then in rip grip. And so we'll go to the next one. So this is something that does exist
and continues to exist. This doesn't quite exist yet. So I'm following it to let me see grams.
It's, you know, it's the name, and it's very, you know, it doesn't work, but it's a coaster's tool
that, in this case, pre-compiles the database to execute NFAs again. So I was thinking how can I
beat rip grip? And the first thing I thought is, well, as I have worked on builds tools, and especially
in modern repos, one of the things that the pants build tool from Twitter does is,
using the file watcher to ensure that, instead of having to constantly read in the entire
contents of a file, which may be very, very large, it only does so when the file has been changed.
So finally, I want to conclude on this note, which is just that the stuff I didn't learn from
e-maxeDevil. I learned from Paul and Katie or Junior, who is the RE2 maintainer. And he taught me
quite a lot from 2023 to 2024. And I'm thankful for the time that I learned from you. So thank you, Paul.
With that, we're at point max. Call me if you want to reach me and/or hire me. These are places that
you can reach me at. There are probably others. Feel free to suggest other ways to kind of like me.
But for now, this is the end. Thank you so much for the time. I really appreciate it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]